the phasing in would begin with the
youngest pupils while the majority of
secondary school pupils will
not attend class until september at the
earliest
the announcement has drawn criticism
from teaching unions who have raised
concerns
over managing social distancing
especially with young children
joining us now is the joint general
secretary for the national education
union
uh kevin courtney hello to you thank you
for joining us on the program this
morning
mr courtney um there was a tweet
yesterday from one of your colleagues dr
mary bastard saying i am amazed at the
recklessness and
incompetence of this government why are
they being reckless in particular would
you say
it's reckless it's irresponsible mary
and i
wrote to the government on the 1st of
may asking them to
talk with us before making any
announcement to get the science
out there where people can see it peer
reviewed about whether this would be
safe
or not they've just ignored that they've
ignored three letters that we've sent
them
about the science we published a report
about those questions recently
they made this announcement last night
with no consultation
with heads or with teachers before
making the announcement it's caused
great
consternation we've surveyed our members
last night within an
hour 49 000 teachers responded to our
survey
with the vast vast majority of them
saying they think it's unsafe that is an
irresponsible way for the government to
go around announcing these sorts of
questions
and we don't agree that it is safe for
schools to reopen
we are not well absolutely not convinced
by the government's statements on that
but with respect they uh we've heard
from the prime minister
and leading politicians they always say
to us during those uh
daily news conferences don't they that
they're following the science
and so that then uh follows that
um it must be the scientists who are
telling them that it is safe for schools
to start to reopen
well we've been offered individual
conversations with chris whitney we'd
like to have them but
individual conversations are not good
enough we've sent a report to the
government
which outlines many international
studies which say that children
are transmitters is of the disease which
says that there are
lots of vulnerable adults who could be
badly affected
which says that social distancing
continues to be really important
the government is not responding to
those things we want
to get back to school
as soon as it safely can and we are not
being irresponsible
we've set five sensible tests the
government hasn't passed its own five
tests yet
and that's i think very important but
we've set five sensible tests that we
think need to be in place and we think
would allow schools to open safely
so we've said the case count in the
country needs to be down
low enough so that contact tracing can
take over some of the work
of social isolation but the case cloud
is nowhere near
those sorts of levels they haven't
recruited their 18 000 contact traces
which wouldn't be enough
they don't have the app working they
aren't ready for that
we've said our second test is they need
to have a plan for social distancing in
schools
they've come up with nothing on that
this suggestion
that uh reception year one and year two
go back
in 700 schools in the country the infant
schools that's the big majority of
children in those schools how can you
possibly do social distancing
when the big majority of children in
classes of 30 or more
are back in the school it makes no sense
we've said they need to have
testing available because otherwise you
don't know if it's running in your
school that's testing for teachers
that they haven't made that work we
don't think the swab test will be good
for children it's too upsetting but
there needs to be
temperature testing symptomatic testing
they have no plan for that and they
won't get that rolled out
by the first of june we've said they
need a plan if there's a case in the
school
what do you then do do you close the
whole class down do you close the whole
school down
we've been given no science on that how
can we be planning
now when they haven't given us any of
those things
okay so you don't want the kids to go
back until it's it's safer i completely
understand that um
you also as a union have told teachers
that recorded and live streamed classes
should be kept to
a minimum while schools are closed why
our members are in school working on
school rotors supporting teach
supporting the children of key workers
putting themselves in harm's way doing
that
they're at home preparing lessons for
children they're at home running
ringing round vulnerable children i i
know the story you're talking about is
an attack piece in the daily telegraph
which absolutely hates my union for no
good reason
we are being sensible and reasonable but
our concern
about live streaming lessons is that we
are getting cases reported to us
of members who have been doing that
where those lessons are
are used mr courtney let's not make it
personal about the daily telegraph
i'm giving you the opportunity to answer
the question about
why you are saying to your members that
they shouldn't stream classes
um while schools are closed so kids are
not supposed to be going to school while
schools are closed
over the summer break let's say that
what what why shouldn't they have a
classic stream we are living in very
uncertain times
absolutely and as i said our members are
our members are preparing lessons
they're ringing around
they're talking to children they're
talking to parents live streaming
lessons have some real security
questions there are some real questions
about privacy that come up with that we
and our members are doing everything
they possibly can
this is an attack piece i make no
apologies for saying it's an attack
piece
it's meant to undermine the fact that we
are saying that schools shouldn't go
back
until they're safe we think that what
we're talking about is the fastest
safe way out of lockdown we think people
should look to what new zealand did
where jacinta and ardern said you had to
go hard you had to go early
to drive the case number down we're very
worried that what the government is
doing now will lead to a spike in cases
we don't want that to be situated
in our schools